who had the most ill-fitting outfit on
miami vice and what was moira's most
outrageous ensemble on shit's creek here
are a few television costuming choices
that may have gone a little overboard
what's worse carrie bradshaw falling
flat on her face during her first ever
runway walk or her wardrobe during the
infamous tumble you be the judge in the
season 4 sex and the city episode the
real me carrie is invited to participate
in a charity fashion show alongside
heidi klum and former mayor ed koch both
of whom appear as themselves while she
was originally slated to wear a dolce
gabbana dress a last-minute change puts
carrie in a pair of bedazzled panties
needless to say she's not a fan of the
idea at first how can i make this clear
me no likey the idea of having one's
groin area literally sparkling with the
radiant reflections of diamonds in the
light is certainly a romantic notion but
that doesn't excuse it being paired with
carrie's puffed-up hairdo and
knee-length glam jacket sex in the city
was always one of the most
fashion-forward shows but this
particular getup was destined to be a
disaster still at least carrie was able
to stand up after her fall and finish
her runway walk without any other
incidents
as an fbi agent who spends most of his
time chasing cryptids fox mulder can't
be expected to stay up to date on
fashion trends even so the early days of
the x-files saddled the beleaguered
believer with some ridiculously
oversized trench coats the choice makes
practical sense since the show was shot
in chile vancouver for its first five
seasons but the sheer size of mulder's
jacket could be an x-file on its own
upon closer examination the jacket is
likely as large as it is in order to
accommodate another fashion faux pas
that hadn't quite been phased out by the
early 1990s the oversized shoulder pads
or mulder suit jacket between the pads
and david duchovny's already broad
shoulders it kinda makes sense that the
jacket needed to be absurdly huge with a
fashion sense like that it's no wonder
it took until season seven for mulder
and scully to finally share their first
official kiss
one of batman's most famous villains the
riddler quickly became a fan favorite on
the original 1960s batman series
starring adam west as the caped crusader
in the first and third seasons of the
show riddler is played by frank gorshin
who earned an emmy nomination for his
performance as the quizzical villain
however for the character's appearance
in season 2 jon aston was cast in the
role instead presumably because gorshin
was unavailable at the time while aston
best known as gomez from the addams
family does a decent enough job as the
riddler he doesn't fill out the
character's costume in quite the same
way gorshin was an extremely skinny man
one of the few actors who could
effectively wear a skintight leotard
without looking unintentionally silly
john astin while not overweight simply
didn't have a body type that was
flattered by such a costume decades
later when jim carrey took on the role
of the riddler in batman forever he wore
a skin-tight leotard costume that paid
tribute to frank gorshin's iconic outfit
thankfully carrie was just as skinny as
gorson so there was no unfortunate
curves on his version of the eccentric
enigma
in the final frontier there will be
unisex minidresses while his intentions
were noble series creator gene
roddenberry's idea of a starfleet
uniform designed for both men and women
ultimately proved to be something of a
misfire for the science fiction series
his reasoning was simple if women in
star trek can wear pants like the men
traditionally do then there should be a
skirt that men can wear too alas the
scant as it was called looked silly in
practice with its tiny sleeves making
its wearers look like uncomfortable
children the scant only made sporadic
appearances in the early days of the
next generation and was quickly phased
out with most of the crew members
transitioning to pants more recently the
animated series star trek lower decks
took a much deserved shot at the
ill-fitting outfit should we be in scans
for this nobody wears those anymore
don't overthink it perhaps if riker or
picard had given the scan a chance the
fashion of star trek would have gone
down a different path as it is however
this awkward minidress is just a
footnote in track history
oliver queen more commonly known as the
green arrow wears a green leather
ensemble that hides his identity while
providing a degree of protection from
physical blows for the most part his
costume is chic and functional allowing
the righteous vigilante to look cool
while fighting to save the city that he
loves unfortunately the version of his
outfit seen in season 4 of arrow doesn't
exactly hit the bull's eye most
glaringly this particular costume is
sleeveless while it does a good job of
showing off steven amell's big arms it
looks more like the wardrobe department
ran out of material during production
his long gloves and arm guards don't do
much to hide how silly the whole thing
looks at times queen's shoulders are
even covered by big rounded shoulder
pads which make him look more like a
ninja turtle than an emerald archer
finally the costume simply isn't green
enough but it was apparently supposed to
be since several scenes put a cheap cg
filter over the suit in an attempt to
make it pop fortunately this was all
fixed in season 5 ditching the bizarre
overlay and bringing sleeves back to the
costume
moira rose played by catherine o'hara in
the hit tv series shit's creek is the
walking definition of over the top not
an episode of the show goes by in which
she doesn't wear a bizarre costume and a
horrific wig to match throughout the
series her outfits run the gamut from
absolute nightmare to okay that's
actually pretty good for the grand
series finale in which moira serves as
the officiant for her son's wedding she
pulls out all the stops and dons the
worst or best outfit ever seen on the
show this particular getup is moira's
take on the pope complete with a long
gown and giant mitre her rig is
relatively normal by her standards
though its blonde locks do inexplicably
line the entire brim of the pope hat the
real cherries on top are the golden
gloves complete with several rings rings
over gloves may be the ultimate fashion
sin but that doesn't stop moira from
doing a fantastic job with the wedding
making for a touching final chapter to
the shit's creek saga
former the shield star michael chicklish
joined the cast of fox's batman origin
story gotham in its second season as
nathaniel barnes a no-nonsense
tough-as-nails cop with a checkered past
when he's infected by a drop of blood
from mad hatter's dead sister he becomes
something even nastier he becomes the
executioner an original villain created
for the show as the executioner barnes
murders criminals which inevitably puts
him into conflict with the more
ethically minded jim gordon he wears
green arrow style grease paint over his
eyes and adorns himself with armor that
looks like something a sinobyte from
hellraiser might wear the awkward armor
is provided to barnes by the court of
owls a secret society that has pulled
gotham strings for generations maybe
that's why they gave him a costume that
looks like it's from a straight to video
sequel to eyes wide shut
suel and mishki arch nemesis of elaine
bennis and heir to the old henry candy
bar fortune may have only appeared on
four episodes of seinfeld but she
certainly made a lasting impression in
her debut on season seven's the caddy
sue ellen refuses to wear a bra while
out in public prompting elaine to buy
one for her as a passive aggressive
birthday present sue ellen responds by
wearing the bra as a top on its own with
nothing but a blazer to cover it up this
unconventional outfit distracts jerry
and kramer while they're on the road
causing a car accident that leads to a
trial parodying the old j simpson case
when asked to put on the bra over her
leotard the garment doesn't fit and just
like johnny cochran famously said about
oj's bloody glove if it doesn't fit
you must acquit of course a bra is not
going to fit on over leotard a bra gotta
fit right up against a person's skin
like a glove
as a result sue ellen goes unpunished
for her crimes against fashion by the
end of the episode the idea of wearing a
bra as a top becomes a huge hit with the
public
decades before denis villeneuve turned
dune into a hollywood blockbuster the
sci-fi channel aired frank herbert's
doom a mini-series based on the
acclaimed 1965 novel produced on a
budget of 20 million dollars the
mini-series aired in 2000 and became a
huge hit for the network there is a wide
variety of factions within the world of
doom and the miniseries way of conveying
these disparate allegiances was to give
each group a different style of costume
often accentuated by distinct headwear
unfortunately these costumes can be more
than a little distracting today frank
herbert's dune is remembered mainly for
its wacky outfits particularly the hats
worn by characters like princess eurelin
but honestly nearly every character can
be described as fashion overkill
this whole list could consist of nothing
but entries from miami vice such was the
glorious audacity of the groundbreaking
series sense of style however the first
place honor has to go to actor timmy
cappello who appeared in season three's
theresa as the enforcer arzola this
gun-toting henchman wears a bizarrely
misshapen tank top that's so ghastly he
ends up taking it off partway through
the episode while he's set up as an
intimidating thug arzola is
unceremoniously killed when he runs into
traffic while trying to escape from
protagonist sunny crockett
across the four seasons of his comedy
central series nathan for you nathan
fielder made a career out of trying to
revitalize struggling businesses through
hilariously unconventional means his
ideas have ranged from abusing you break
it you buy it policies to selling a one
dollar tv guarded by a live alligator
all with varying degrees of success
however one of his more bizarre and
messy plans involved a plastic suit
filled with delicious chili in a season
4 episode filder meets with a chilly
shop owner whose dream is to sell his
food at a nearby hockey stadium
unfortunately the stadium isn't offering
contracts to outside vendors fielder's
plan to smuggle chile into the arena to
sell by hiding it in a custom-built
bodysuit after some rigorous testing and
a few redesigns the show's host dons the
covert chili dispenser and actually
manages to sneak it past security under
some plus-sized hockey merch believe it
or not the plan is relatively successful
as fielder is able to sell 16 bowls and
bring back a 20 profit whether or not it
was worth carrying 30 pounds of chili
around for over an hour is a different
story check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you